découverte du folklore local
les six délégations européennes
participant au programme ready t'avais
rendez-vous en pologne pour cette
dernière réunion consacrée à la ruralité
en europe
la maison de l'europe des yvelines fait
partie de ce projet depuis deux ans nous
avons une grande diversité d'expériences
à la fois par la taille d expérience à
la fois des expériences le bâti des
expériences culinaires des expériences
culturelles de très belles rencontres
financé par le programme erasmus plus
des rencontres transnationales ont déjà
eu lieu en suède ou encore en grèce
les objectifs sont identiques partager
des expériences ou encore promouvoir la
citoyenneté active dans des zones
rurales
au programme pour cette visite en
pologne découverte d'un musée école d'un
ranch polonais ou encore de produits
locaux
cette posture renie cosmétiques c'était
une très belle rencontre
c'est vraiment très important de montrer
les zones rurales en pologne
c'est très important pour moi comme pour
tous les autres participants
je m'aperçois que même si les
initiatives n'ont aucun rapport avec le
spectacle les problématiques sont les
mêmes c'est à dire que on voit plein de
points qui pour le développement sont
importants à avoir
que ce soit pour un musée ou pour
présenter un produit balle et il ya
plein de clés qui sont similaires et qui
pourrait être très intéressante à
creuser pour développer les des
initiatives en milieu rural ce projet
read heat qui a pris fin avec ce voyage
en pologne va permettre l'édition d'un
guide de travail numériques sur le
développement local dans les zones
rurales